How do you do?
My name's Masa.
I'm Boss Tatsu's sworn brother.
Oh, so you're Masa!
Nice to meet you, I'm Miku.
Sorry I didn't tell you in advance,
but I came today for Boss's…
-Birthday!
Tacchan's out for shopping
and the Neighborhood Association meeting.
He won't be back until the evening.
So I've been preparing the decorations
and the cake as a surprise!
All right. Perfect!
I'd be happy to help, Boss Lady!
Really? That'd be great!
I was just slicing
some fruit for the cake.
CHOP
Wait, Boss Lady…
Let me do it.
Are you sure?
So slow!
You gotta be faster and really whack 'em!
Hold on, let's guugle it first.
Hey!
KER-CHAK
I'm home… Huh?
What the hell happened?
LEAN, PULL, POP
We screwed up.
So that's what went down, eh?
I'll avenge you!
Amazing as usual, Tacchan!
You nailed it, Boss!
Happy birthday dear me